Denny Hamlin driver of the number 11
FedEx Toyota Camry car big winner last
night the rain shortened Toyota 500 race
from Darlington he and his crew unveiled
the number 11 FedEx small business paint
scheme ahead of this weekend's race in
Charlotte and it pays tribute to small
business owners the real backbone of
America which is represented through the
stars on the car
Denny joins us on the program how you
feeling today I'm good I kind of knew
this interview is coming so I had to put
up a good performance to make sure my
z'd it yeah if you weren't on the show
would you have won last night is that
what you're saying I think we've talked
about this right I mean I think Paul
knows guys have talked about you come on
there and you win I don't want the word
to get out Denny then we'll be inundated
with drivers trying to win is is the job
different first of all you're racing on
a Wednesday night and you're racing you
know with what's going on with no fans
there how different is that it's
different I mean it's just it's quiet I
mean I don't I can't express like just
the silence of it is is the biggest
thing inside the race car where the race
is going on we don't notice a huge
difference but when you get out and you
win the race that's like okay the back
of your bikes prettier your resume the
media availability that's that's when
things become a little different did you
pour like a drink on your head like do
you celebrate at all I haven't but I
will in due time do you smoke the tires
I mean what do you come on no well we
know because you know we got to reuse
this engine in another race so I got you
know I got an email the night the night
before I hate this engine no burnout do
you ever have to get like you gear up
for the weekend but here it is a
Wednesday night it is it is it different
to gear up for a Wednesday night race as
opposed to a weekend race well we
usually you know like like golf you know
we have one event per week usually well
now we're doing two per week for the
next few months trying to catch up and
so the the biggest issue we have in
Motorsports is dehydration right I mean
it's so hot in the cars you sweat out so
much it takes you days to get that back
well now we used to have a week to get
it back now we just got a couple days
before we're back in a car again so the
fatigue factor is the biggest thing that
we need to kind of be aware of do you
ever eat during a race sometimes I mean
you get some snacks in there every now
and then but I haven't done it in years
I I kind of just load up for forehand i
assuming you watched the last dance
since you're buddies with Michael Jordan
did you see anything in there that
surprised you um
surprised me well you know that
competitive side of him you've seen it
so I knew it but and obviously you hear
stories you read articles things like
that but you kind of don't you don't
understand you know I I was so young
when when all this stuff was going on
but like I didn't I wasn't able to
appreciate it now I remember watching
that you know 97 98 finals but I don't I
didn't remember the significance of it
and so going back and seeing everyone's
testimony and everyone talking about it
was was amazing and for me I was like I
tell me if that doesn't get you jacked
up it's like perform at your best and
push all your teammates to perform
better I don't know what is and and so
you know I I talked to them last night a
little bit as well you know people don't
know that Darlington is the racetrack
that grew his love for NASCAR racing his
dad used to take him to Darlington every
year so that's where he you know got
that relationship and to win they're
kind of right after last dance and
things pretty cool you ever taken him
for a ride-along no I don't think you I
don't think he'll do it first of all
getting them in a car it's gonna be
that'd be a problem
I mean we're you know we're not jockeys
burning them but we're you know we're
not either I remember them they have
enough when Shaq got in a race car they
had to like cut out the Centers of this
race Park might expand it so you could
get in
but can that now there is their weight I
guess the car has to be a certain every
car has to be a certain weight yeah okay
so if Shaq like Shaq couldn't be a demon
if you could put Shaq in a car I'd have
to get rid of like yeah like the engine
everyone else yes you can't shut enough
metal off but if you is there an
advantage to weighing less in this car
no because they always they base it off
of a 200-pound driver so if you weigh
190 you have to add 10 pounds and so
they they even it out that way
who would have a personality similar to
Michael Jordan's in NASCAR from the
competitive side yeah I don't know that
there's anyone as competitive as I am
I mean maybe Kyle Busch with you know
being kind of sometimes tough on his
team things like that but he's just
trying to push same as Michael those
guys too to get to the next level we're
talking to Denny Hamlin driver the
number 11 FedEx Toyota Camry car had the
win last night next up is Charlotte I
believe that right this weekend yeah
yeah and you talked about it the small
business and they're actually providing
your grant for small businesses million
dollars is available in grant money so I
encourage everyone to go to fedex.com
back-back space
sports small grants and and see if you
can get a get a grant for them so yeah
they just been a huge supporter of my
career this is my 15th year now with
them we got the coke 600 coming up this
weekend in Charlotte and then we go back
there on Wednesday so we're cramming a
lot of races in here in a very short
amount of time did you ever drive a ride
a FedEx truck I did I've delivered race
tickets I believe it was out in Phoenix
went out on a full uniform full uniform
yeah they were surprised explain the
middle finger etiquette in NASCAR with
chase Elliott last night yeah actually a
pretty good form with it
I had three knuckles up you know you
know he didn't you know move his hand
around he just kept it steady right
there in line with the car so there's a
good form in my opinion okay but what is
middle finger worthy on the track I
don't know I guess that one probably was
I mean we ought you know everyone that
knows racing knows that you know it was
an accident but still you know he got
screwed in the process
yeah worked out good for me but yeah
it's you know the one thing that really
does piss me off though is getting it
while you're racing like you know guy
you're racing a guy and maybe bump into
him whatever any sixes middle finger out
out of the window and you can see it
like it's time to send them what you
mean tell you you gotta send them in the
fence don't be giving me the middle
finger what if I give you the double
bird that means you're in the fence
because no one no hands are on the wheel
[Laughter]
but you haven't been in a fight in a
while right last year we had a little
tussle with Joey Logano again we butt
heads a little bit you know he kind of
came over to talk to me and I I'm
cordial I stood there like a man and
wanted to talk to him and that's all
good but then kind of as he walked away
it kind of gave me a shove in the
shoulder as he was walking away and you
know I liked your fire but he's got some
reach on you Danny yeah he does but you
know big man like that's gotta have slow
reflexes well congrats on the win last
night good luck this weekend always
great to check in with you thanks for
joining us thanks Dan see you guys
appreciate it that's Denny Hamlin driver
the number 11 FedEx Toyota and win last
night